[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Darkhorse
podcast I have the distinct pleasure of
sitting this afternoon with Brad
schismus who is the lead singer the
marimba player and the harpsicord for
the band five times August actually I
don't know that it has any of those
things in it I do know that you uh you
have a a wide variety of stuff going on
Brad welcome to
Darkhorse most people are probably not
going to have um heard of you unless
they are connected into certain
dissident circles can you give us a
sense of uh who you are and where you
came
from yeah so I started um five times
August when I was 18 like right after
high school and um you know I kind of at
that time wanted to be a you know just
acoustic singer songwriter kind of guy
uh John Mayor is Dave Matthews Band kind
of upand cominging songwriter and uh
down that path I ended up getting songs
licensed to MTV and ended up touring a
lot of colleges back then and this was
about 2003 or four and that's what I did
for about 10 years doing songs um you
know pop love songs um during the
country had some albums in Walmart and
Best Buy stores and I was doing stuff um
took a break when I became a family man
started up a kids music project called
the Juicebox jukebox and that's what I
was kind of doing um prior to the covid
world and then it kind of shut me down
musically and then I came back sort of
uh as this kind of protest artist
writing about what was happening in the
world so this is certainly how I became
aware of you and I must tell you the
first time I heard a song of yours it uh
it's almost Indescribable it gave me a
kind of Hope at a moment that was
extremely
dark um the co dissident and I consider
you very much a CO dissident with a
special
Skillet um but the co dissidents faced
an
absolutely Unholy world where we were
being demonized in very close quarters
and very personally as if we were
somehow morally defective and so selfish
that we would not go along with uh you
know the slightest inconvenience even to
save the lives of our family members and
you know our countrymen that was a very
ugly period and to hear
somebody rise up musically and challenge
that order and do it so
eloquently the song in question the one
that brought you to my attention was sad
little man which is a song about Anthony
fouchy and you know there's so much
about it that I still just feel is is
important including the recognition that
this strangely powerful person who as
unbelievable as it sounds was not only
responsible for our terrible response to
covid but also likely responsible for
its creation that's a tremendous amount
of power and to
musically put him in his place and
describe him as the the pitiful creature
that he must be in order for him to do
what he did was it was brilliant and it
it was heartening and I know it was
heartening to many not just
me thank you um yeah I uh you know up to
that point I was sort of writing on a on
a broader scope on what was happening in
the world and there was this figure that
was very Godlike to a certain side of
the aisle that I felt like like nobody
is g to like call this guy out you know
and and I felt like um you know the song
itself I wrote in a way that wasn't if
you listen to the song by itself it
doesn't say Anthony fouchy it doesn't
even say you know the word vaccine in it
or anything I wanted to write something
that would sound just as good 20 years
from now and and have historical uh
backstory to it so when you're like oh I
wonder who he was writing about you know
and then when you look into you go and
it's not really till you see the video
of that song that you're like oh yeah
that's that's Anthony fouchy because I
what I did was sort of create this
animated video of him as a snake oil
snake oil salesman traveling through
these different towns and ultimately the
town catches up to him and um but it was
it was something else like it was
something that I hadn't done before in
my career where I'm calling somebody out
directly I'm putting their face into the
video and saying this is the guy um not
sure what the repercussions were going
to be um just overall and uh it did
definitely put me on another level of
what was happening um because shortly
after that my Wikipedia page had
disappeared after 10 years um YouTube
was censoring the video for medical
misinformation which really like is
absurdly ridiculous because there's
nothing you can pinpoint about the song
or the video it's just that they didn't
like it obviously um so things like that
started happening after that
song interesting um you I guess I had
never put together um that you don't
mention Anthony fouchy there I love that
and I'm uh I'm
reminded of the story of uh
The Beatles song I guess I'm not
entirely sure I know the title of the
song But Here Come little flat
top um come together come together right
exactly um you you know the story of
that
song I know tons of Beatles lore but uh
you go
ahead um in this case that song was
written as a campaign song for Timothy
lery who was running for governor of
Cali
California and I hope I have the story
right but
um John Lennon was asked about the fact
that he had used it uh even though it
was written for Timothy lry and you know
it doesn't mention Timothy Larry um but
he said it was a little bit like you
know at the dry cleaner at some point if
you don't pick up your suit we're going
to use it for something um so anyway the
idea that such an iconic song you know
yes may have been written about Timothy
ly
but it it extends beyond that and I like
the idea that your uh your your sad
little man uh is ready for the next
person who inhabits such a role and it
will uh no doubt fit them equally but
that brings me to another point which is
your songs aren't just songs you put
together these videos and we will end up
uh showing another song of yours here
shortly but these videos are extremely
artfully put together and you know it's
it I'm I'm a little bit reminded of the
uh animations that come with Monty
Python
basically uh I I don't want to overly
describe it but the the story of Anthony
fouchy as the sad little man is told in
this very compelling way that does
reduce him to this
two-dimensional uh character with you
know the power to shoot syringes out of
his mouth and and things like this um
but I did want to call attention am I
right you do the video in addition to
the music yeah I do um the videos are
sort of an extension of the song itself
and uh you know I knew early on as I was
writing these songs um they just needed
that visual documentation to go along
with it it's one thing to write the song
and put it out and hope people hear it
but and and you know it's just the times
we live in such a visual visually
gratifying time that when you see it and
connect the visual with what I'm saying
and the fact it's all coming from the
same Source um it adds a different
element to it in feeling and um I don't
think I could hire anybody to make these
videos the way I do anyway because I put
so much thought into each frame almost
that um I want you to watch it you know
10 times over because there's a lot of
Easter eggs and little details that um
you can pick up on after you watch it
the first or second time you'll go back
and see something new every single time
yeah that's absolutely true the number
of little details I I I went back and I
watched a couple of your uh your videos
today and I spotted things I'd never
seen before um so yes they are extremely
rich and layered and very compelling and
the music is irresist
so anyway it's you know it's it's sort
of the full the full artistic package
and um I don't know how much you know
about me I'm I'm an evolutionary
biologist and uh I think a lot about
questions like what is music why why
does it exist it's a it's a huge expense
that uh every human culture invests in
and um and I
know that it uh has the power to move
mountains and I know that when it's
absent it is a A desperate sign in fact
one of the things that um troubled
Heather and me about the BLM movement
was that it was so toned deaf that there
was something it was it was just it was
malformed that its chants were just
discordant and troubling and there was
no they didn't even aspire to beautiful
movement it was just ugly at its
Inception and so anyway you you're
showing us the flip side you're using
and you know the what kind of world are
we living in that you can
um create a piece of art that doesn't
even name the person in question that
levels an accusation only if you
understand what has been taking place
and the idea is well then we all know
what was taking place so you definitely
leveled an ACC accusation and that
accusation is incorrect by definition so
therefore I don't know if they threw you
off or uh removed the videos or what
they did but the idea that they would
take action against art tells you
exactly who they
are yeah that um was a real eye opener
for me because as an artist you know
stepping into
this this uh this field of just speaking
out in general you know I before I
released these songs I was sort of
Dipping my toe into posts online you
know just sort of saying my opinion here
and there on Facebook and it was
something I hadn't done before because I
knew I was about to upset a certain you
know I had two decades worth of fans so
I was like I I I worked really hard over
the years to just be right in the middle
and you know bring everybody together
through music that's what it's about and
unifies us and um once I started
speaking out out um yeah you saw that uh
that sort of tsunami hit you of of anger
and resentment and uh is just an
interesting thing to see to experience
um but uh I forget where I was going
with that but uh you just sort of
trailed me down memory lane there yep
well maybe that uh leads us um to the
next question which is um so you have a
new song out and the song again struck
me very powerfully and it it dovetails
with some of what you've already said
about your own origin story that
you you were trying to be a rock and
roller you were you know you weren't out
to make waves you were out to make
music and then as it has happened to
many of us history happened to you and I
don't know what it is that clued you in
to the broken nature of the official
narrative on
covid
um do you know what it
was well so my oldest son I have three
kids and my oldest had been injured by
his early childhood shots and so my wife
had gone down this Rabbit Hole long ago
so by the time Co came around I had
heard so many things in my ether but as
a bumbling dad you just sort of feel oh
that's you know we'll worry about that
one you know that's something to think
about and I think a lot of dads are like
that so you know thank God for the
Google moms who really let their mother
bear instincts kick in and and so that
stuff was in my ether then by the time
covid came around it was at my
doorstep and um
you know you could see what was
happening The Masks were coming in
Social distancing none of it made sense
um and I felt like I needed to speak up
you know for my kids sake I didn't like
the way the world was what it was
turning into and I didn't want them to
look back 10 or 20 years down the road
and be like you know what did you do
back then about it and right I had a
platform so I decided to sort of you
know step forward and and uh say
something but it was also um you know
looking around wondering where my
musical Heroes were because they weren't
showing up my my whole life is music not
just writing it but it's how I spend my
leisurely time listening to music
shopping for records like that's what
I've done since I was a kid so I had
these Heroes that I had anticipated to
say something and you know most of them
didn't and then the other half that did
made a fizer commercial or you know a
tweet telling you to be cool and get
vaxed um And Then There Was You know
guys like Eric Clapton and Van Morrison
out of that generation and they were the
only two to really say anything at all
um so it's was really disheartening so
yeah I have a new song out now called
ain't no rock and roll which is
addressing this
entire um emotion of looking at rock and
roll and realiz realizing that maybe it
was a farce the whole time because there
was never a greater time to speak up
against the man than right now the last
three years the door was wide open to
say damn the man and you know like I
said very very very few of them actually
showed up yeah almost none and it's
stunning in light of all the lyrics we
could all recite all of the things that
they led us to believe that they
believed if they believed him at all
they sure is held on anymore it's it's
amazing um my suggestion is so that
people have some idea what we're talking
about that we play that song now and I
will say uh a large fraction of our
audience listens on podcast but the
visuals here are important too you will
understand a lot better um the full uh
nature of the accusation leveled in this
beautiful song If you watch it so if you
can't watch it right now consider going
back when you're sitting at a screen
that's uh capable of showing it to you
and finding the song and looking at the
video it's it's really really
good um all right so let's play
[Music]
it
well there rain no rocking Ru ever since
they sold out Rolling
Stone all the words that were sung in
the past will never feel the same when
we're looking
back all the old men sitting in their
makeup chair with the gold wed walls
really couldn't care all the fame feels
the same when you've had enough so they
don't bother standing
[Music]
up and there ain't no peace in love ever
since the' 60s kids grew
up all the drugs in the girls in the
cash after all the songs it was gone in
a Flash
all those bad boy rebels in the attitude
what a show we didn't know that none of
it was true only Self Serve
antiestablishment we were all so
innocent because there ain't no rock and
roll and the blues has lost it
Soul all the PS gave the man
control and every pop stars fall in Soul
no there Ain no ain't no rock and
roll and there ain't no Jonah no Bob no
one stuck around for the protest
job all the stars in the Big Farm of
whse chilling for a check from their
corporate
Shores all the actors say what they're
pay to stay while the fans take the
[Music]
blame all the on cool fools that were me
and you well they pushed us all away
pushed us all away because there ain't
no rock and
roll in the flu is lost it
so all the punks gave the man
control and every Punk STS fall in the
sow no there rain no Ain no Rocking
R and there ain't no boss no Queen never
was a rage against the damn
machine nor there rain no fighter in the
foo no more rocking in those free world
shoes all the high strong Neil Young
want a beast yeah this Silence has been
different
in all the suits lick the boots of the
government what they sang they never
meant because there ain't no rocking
roll
and the blues has lost its
Soul all the PKS gave the man
control and every pop stars Bing the
soul no there a no Ain no rock and
roll no there a no ain't no rock and
roll
no there a no ain't no rocking
roll all the rain no Ain no rock and
[Music]
roll all right so it is
uh quite a song and my guess is it can't
have been easy for you to write that
song about people that you clearly
respected you know it's funny because I
wrote that song last November and I it
had it was inevitable it's I almost feel
like it was the first song that I wrote
even though it wasn't but the emotion
that is in the song that really drove me
to speak we out you know was sort of the
Genesis of this entire
whole um Avenue that I've been down
musically so it was going to happen and
then when I wrote it I thought yeah you
know that's that's really saying
something and and you know how how much
more rock and roll can you get than
calling out rock and roll as it stands
now um it's funny to be
considered uh something of a rebel now
looking at all those guys and those
figures in the video um I I I was never
going to be that I was never going to be
sex drugs and rock and roll I was just a
a cleancut acoustic guitar guy um but it
turns out that being a family man and um
you know just sticking to your
convictions um as a father and um you
know somebody who cares about their
country is the most rebellious thing
that you can be um in these times so
yeah and and then putting the video
together was another thing because I was
looking at there's a lot of my heroes in
that video former Heroes where I'm like
ah it pains me to put you in here but
this is the way it is now you know I I I
I feel like I
gave so much grace more than I should
have to say when you coming to say
something when you know when is when is
Bob going to say something when is um
you know Paul McCartney or you know we
all expected Neil Young to be one of
those guys Bruce Springstein Rage
Against the Machine um and and they just
completely let us down and then you see
not just did they not show up but like
what are they in the news for over the
last three years Neil Young's angry
about misinformation he's drawing a Line
in the Sand saying you can either have
me or Joe Rogan well he lost that battle
and then Bruce Springstein is having uh
you know uh vaccinated only audiences
that was a big one to be like what are
y'all doing segregating your audience um
in a in a in a place where that's
supposed to unite us despite our
differences at concerts you know it
doesn't matter what what your political
affiliation is or anything you stand
there together and you sing these songs
and then you go home and you say that
was great that was very unifying and all
of a
sudden uh vaccinated only can get in or
a special vaccination clinic set up at
the concerts all this crazy stuff um and
then yeah so the joke became Rage
Against the Machine you know is is now
raging for the machine and I think you
know everybody saw it everybody saw it
happen in real time so it's very
disappointing well when I saw your song
I had this odd feeling because the music
is you know I won't call it folk it's
not exactly folk I don't want to insult
you by pigeon ho holding you into a
genre but it sure is how closer to folk
than it is punk but my thought
was this is the new Punk right this is
somebody who actually is saying it like
it is and doing it in spite of the fact
that it's personally painful to call out
your own Heroes and say where the hell
were you m I gave you how long and you
didn't show up in fact you showed up on
the other side what's wrong with you
well a lot of us are there I mean I will
point out maybe you're you know you're
an unlikely
punk I don't know what I'm I'm supposed
to be a a nerd I'm a biologist right I'm
supposed to be eeking out on uh you know
I don't know protein synthesis or
something and here I am like fighting
the man so I guess we we are all called
by this terrible situation
into roles that we did not imagine we
would be in right yeah you know that was
something that uh was that that sort of
woke me up was that it happened
simultaneously watching my musical
Heroes become sort of the the dorks and
sellouts or whatever but then the
doctors and the scientists that actually
risked everything that actually did
speak up against the band they became
the rock stars to me they were now like
the rock and roll
and I think that that's so crazy how the
Paradigm has shifted over the last three
years because nothing is what it was so
which is very exciting too because it it
brings back the attitude of it all like
I'm clearly I don't look like a punk
rocker but my attitude in doing what a
punk rocker would do is there and the
same sense that doctor speaking out is
very rock and roll and so you know
that's
that's a new kind of thing I don't know
what you call that it's you know because
I do think rock and roll as it as it was
like I said earlier is a is sort of just
a farce it's a T-shirt and Target store
at this point you know there's all these
grunge bands that you know started in
the 90s you had Pearl Jam and Nirvana
and now they're just that t-shirt it's
their logo on a t-shirt at Target which
was the very antithesis of everything
that they were singing about back in
those days um so there's something new
happening and um there are you know
there's there's new artists speaking out
it's Independent Artists who aren't
Tethered to major labels and um managers
and stuff and and we're starting to sort
of find each other um there there's
artists that have been kicked out of
bands very popular bands that um have
found each other there's a new band
called The defiant who is sort of a
super group of guys that have gotten
kicked out of their bands um one of
those being Pete PDA of the band The
Offspring from everybody knows their
hits from the 90s um he's teamed up with
Dicky Barrett from the band The Mighty
Mighty Boston there's a guy in the band
in that very band from Smashmouth who
wrote Allstar and walking on the sun all
these songs so they they've created a
new like they're the rock and rollers
right like if you're wondering where
they were they braved it they went
through it they they convened together
and they have an album coming out and
that stuff's really exciting to me to
see well it's really exciting to me too
and I have a number of thoughts that
follow from that forgive me this is one
of my defects as a uh as a podcast host
is that I'm going to put a couple things
on the table at once which it is what it
is
um a the
analogy between what you're seeing in
music what we saw in medicine what we
saw in science
is uh quite close right the entire
institution of science failed the entire
institution of Medicine of Journalism
these things revealed how bankrupt they
were but in each case a tiny number of
people and really compared to the size
of the institutions it's tiny but they
created I don't think they knew that
this was what they were doing but they
created Grassroots institutions that
substitute for the failed institutions
that just couldn't be rescued and you
know the idea of a superg group composed
of people thrown out of their bands
because they wouldn't take a vaccine or
wouldn't inflict vaccines On Their
audience wow that is a hell of an origin
story right that is powerful stuff yeah
so it's heartening that um that that
process right let's put it this way the
tiny number of people was really close
to zero MH but it wasn't zero it was a
small small number of people who I will
say
were and really the story that you've
told us makes this clear it is the small
number of people who were willing to
take a financial hit a major one maybe
even an unrecoverable one in order to do
and say the right thing and the real
story is why is that so rare we are so
pleased pleas to have as our sponsor for
this episode the wellness company
world-renowned experts like Dr Peter
McCulla have partnered with the wellness
company to create real change in
healthcare they offer a wide variety of
supplements and services including tella
health emergency medical kits with icin
and teams of medical professionals that
can help assist patients kick the
pharmaceutical habit with their freedom
from Pharma program the wellness company
has all sorts of useful and important
products we like their Mito support as
in mitochondria which is formulated to
provide energy both physical and mental
and their Spike support formula their
most popular product is useful for those
not only who have been vaccinated but
anyone who may be suffering from long
covid as well as the wellness company
says on their website if you're looking
to get back to that pre-co feeling their
Spike support formula can help Spike
support is made with a combination of
natural ingredients like nyise dandelion
root extract selenium black sativa
extract Irish seamos and green tea
extract these ingredients all contain
immune boosting capabilities and the
nines specifically has been used by the
Japanese for decades because of its
ability to dissolve blood clots but more
recently ninas has been shown to be able
to break down Spike proteins in the
bloodstream and even block them from
binding to cells Dr Mulla says out of
all the available therapies I've used in
my practice and among all proposed
detoxification agents I believe ninas
and related peptides hold the greatest
promise whether you've taken a vaccine
or just had covid if you're concerned
about circulating Spike proteins go to
tww c. Health Darkhorse and use the code
Darkhorse to save 15% on your first
order that's tww c. Health SL Darkhorse
code Darkhorse to save
15% that was something that I I told my
wife for months as I started speaking
out because especially as an indie
artist if you're lucky enough to make a
making music you've already won the
lottery you know um it's a very rare
thing and then to speak up against what
the industry is telling you to do um you
know and that parallel runs with with uh
you know doctors and scientists as well
because there's a certain expectation on
how you should behave and what you
should say um but when you go against it
um
yeah you feel the you feel the brunt of
it but um out of that
um has come I've been really talking
about this a lot lately like we're at
this turning point this stuff that
didn't exist three years now exists and
it's a great Silver Lining of it all um
you know the I found myself as a
songwriter in this journey and these
bands and artists that are now speaking
up that actually um have something to
say after years of watching sort of
music turn into fluff that doesn't mean
anything it's become very formulaic and
it's basically just what I call hump
music you know it's just out there and
it's just it doesn't mean anything it's
and so um yeah but but there's a
beautiful thing happening communities of
all of all different kinds and and once
these different Lanes line up um that's
the new world and that's that's super
exciting to me because that you know
there's we now know who which doctors to
trust you know which which scientists um
have integrity which artists have
something to say and really mean it who
are willing to risk it all and it is a
it is a rare thing you know I because of
I think maybe
the the pace at which life is designed
for us to live by um nobody has time to
risk you know their bills and you know
we got to get to work and then we got to
get home and cook and then we got to get
the kids to bed and we're all just
trying to pay our bills and like I don't
have you know for the the average person
um they're just trying to get by so they
don't want to think about you know uh
taking a risk they'd rather just put the
mask on right and just go along to get
along and I was having this conversation
earlier today about you know imagine had
we all stepped forward at one time
um you know there were pockets of us
that did um and we we have made it here
this far and there are more waking up
but if we all had stepped forward at one
time you know how much crap would we be
dealing with right now probably far less
and hopefully um we can encourage more
people to take that risk moving forward
hopefully people are going you know what
I've had enough you know yeah went along
with it early on you know there are
those people I I went along with it
early on but then I caught on you know
well it's going to take people longer
than others and you know those
conversations need to be had I think you
know there certainly isn't um any
amnesty for certain people in the media
um but um on on a personal level on a
community level I think those
conversations should and can be had
because I think a lot more people have
woken up than um you know certainly the
media gives us credit for but I I guess
I'm rambling but uh that's to say
there's something happening well there
is something a couple things happening
and I want to come back to two of them
but specifically on your last
point I want to describe it as I see it
um and there is a part of me I will just
confess that is hoping uh that when you
hear it this way it will inspire you and
you will put something devastating
together to make this point in a way
that I can't
possibly so I'm not expecting that to
happen but it would be lovely if it did
here here's the point we got almost
nobody is taking these covid
boosters
okay we did that we broke their
narrative their [__] that they were
using to inflict these dangerous shots
on people including children for whom
there was never the slightest argument
for doing it mhm
we broke their
narrative almost nobody is
listening that's
great but why with 98% of people at
least not eager to get that shot are we
still
isolated my feeling is now it has gotten
much less expensive to stand up and I
don't like that people who woke up as a
result of the fact that some courageous
people put their careers on the line and
in fact lost job after job got
demonetized had suffered a direct hit on
their family's
well-being after people put that much at
risk it is now time that you can stand
up and say yep I had it wrong I was
standing in the wrong place now I get it
and now I've got these people's back
because they had our back when we
weren't being very nice to
them yeah it needs to happen
um I think
that
it's we all want that I'm sorry you know
I was
wrong and this is coming
from you're the reason why it's so hard
to get there is because they called you
a murderer they ended 20 year 30 year
lifelong friendships and family
relationships over this thing um you
know they thought
you know one to two shots to get your
life back and now you know and and and
the moment you know the moment I saw
that that uh covid-19 vaccination card I
was like I remember getting uh uh having
conversations with friends where I'm
like you know there's four spots on that
card for a reason right and they're like
a you know whatever so there's so much
duped that they're so in it it would
take so much letting go of their ego to
come back around to even say I'm sorry
but it's
also to your point there's action needs
to be taken right and and we see guys
like like I separate it in in there's
the there's the everyday average person
but then there's these these monsters in
the media there's guys like Pierce
Morgan who said the n EST things and
then one day decide to walk back right
oh I'm so glad we don't have to wear
masks anymore whatever it is that you
know hit him and he starts walking back
slowly and it's Our obligation to say no
no no you don't get to do that what do
you if you really feel that way what are
you going to do about it how are you
going to rectify what you've
participated in and um go ahead well I
just wanted to
say it's not even Rectify what you you
participated in there may be nothing you
can do about that I'm not even really
looking for I'm sorry I'll take it I
think there are a lot of apologies owed
but it's really not what I want what I
want is your rock solid assurance that
you understand what happened and will
never do it again that's what I want I
want safety going forward for me my kids
all of the people who stood with us
against this madness those people
deserve never to face that again in
their life and to the extent that people
I don't even think they understand that
they switch sides you were told you were
telling people get your shot if not
you're a bad person and now you're not
getting your
shot and you don't maybe you think
you're putting it off no you're afraid
you now realize how dangerous these
things are you're afraid to get it as
you should be but that fear we tried to
tell you back before you got any of them
and now is the time for you to say you
know what that didn't sound true to me
at the time I now know how confused I
can be I won't do that again no more
witch hunting I'm out I will not hunt
witches because witches don't exist
witches are the people trying to tell
you this is not good for you or your
children yeah I think that it's it's
hard
because you for people like us that have
been so deep down
this sort of you you know they you would
call it a rabbit hole right there's
people that are not even on the
circumference of it up top they're
100,000 miles that direction and you're
right you know they don't know they
don't know that they've switched sides
because they're just kind of following
the wave of things and it really
illustrates actually just how um you
know it illustrates that mass formation
right that that we've all sort of fallen
in line not all of us have fall in line
with but so many have everything has
sort of become a football team so to
speak where what team are you on are you
on team mask or anti- science altogether
right there's these big labels on the
other side um and I think that there's a
huge SWA of people that know you know
innately something's wrong but they
don't know how they don't have the
information they're just waiting to see
where it goes and and and and a lot has
happened because of people like us
breaking down that narrative piece by
piece and it's really good to see it but
yeah I think I like your way better you
know in the sense of just like the
assurance that look you know you don't
even have to say you're you're sorry
just don't do it again and promise me
that that's actually exactly right yeah
I mean seriously that that is the deal I
will explicitly make if you put if you
put it right so that we know where you
stand you're clear about it and you're
not going to do it again we're Square I
don't need your apology right I know
that you probably thought you were doing
the right thing at the time I get that
yeah but it needs to never happen again
because we're talking about like the
literal safety of
children it couldn't be more important
right um so I wanted to point to another
something uh if we can go back to
something you said earlier the group of
people who emerged the courageous
dissidents who fought together and
endured these terrible Slanders um they
give me a tremendous hope I will
certainly say to anybody who's trying to
understand the lesson of where we are
and how we got here wow is it painful to
lose friends and colleagues and people
you thought you could trust because the
mass formation of the moment tells them
that you must be the villain that's
really unpleasant on the other hand it
is telling you something you need to
know it's telling you who can't handle
it and you don't want to think you can
handle it or somebody can handle it and
trust them in a moment where you
discover that and you can't afford it so
reality has done us a favor by revealing
the people who just couldn't shoulder
the burden that they had and it has done
us a great service revealing those who
could who frankly we wouldn't know their
names if this terrible chapter had not
unfolded in a way that revealed them but
I am put in Mind of a a little model
that I
keep uh again you're not going to know
this uh you'd have to you know people
who watch the podcast know that I had a
discussion with a guy Steve Patterson
and he and I agree that we are in a
scientific Dark Age even though it
doesn't look like one it's a cryptic
Dark Age but anyway my model of a Dark
Age involves the fact that it is always
true when our scientific understanding
of the world gives way in favor of
whatever the uh you know the dangerous
mysticism is that replaces it there are
always people who continue to practice
science quietly privately and I call
them keepers of the flame right and I
think what you have described suggests
to me that music is the same way almost
the entire music industry almost
everybody you could name failed they
revealed that all of the lyrics if they
had ever meant them they stopped meaning
them mhm but a number of people emerged
and they demonstrated the strength of
character it's small compared to the
number who failed but my guess would be
that music is going to reemerge that
there's going to be a a Revival of deep
important music and frankly who do you
want to listen to somebody who just
revealed that they don't get it and
aren't honorable enough to uh you know
to admit that they screwed it up or do
you want to listen to the people who
stood up under Fire and figured out how
to phrase this stuff so that we could
all see it you know that sounds like the
beginning of a new musical movement and
interestingly I don't think it has a
genre I think it's it it stretches
across all genres anybody who stood up
I'm interested yeah yeah um you know the
guys that are coming out these sort of
underground Indie artists that have have
said their what they've wanted to say
that have been documenting this time
they're they're the new wave of things I
think um and it does it does cross uh
multitude of genres I mean there's um
there's are you know there's several big
rappers that are now busted into
Billboard charts and actually competing
with mainstream rap there's guys like
Bryson gray and then there's um uh Jimmy
Levy and highy resz have been putting
out great stuff um and then there's the
new band I was telling you about the
defiant which is like a super group of
of punk rockers right um there's even a
guy named foundering on on um Twitter
who does rag time and um it's really
great to see because it it's it's the
message right it's about the feeling
it's not even so much the genra anymore
it's not that that's rock and roll but
but what you're describing is the
feeling of it right it's it's the
message behind it and um yeah there's
there's an opportunity there there's
this is the foundation for the future
right of art and culture to get back to
uh art that means something you see a
lot of people sharing there's a lot of
like Twitter accounts that'll share old
culture and say what happened right look
at this marble statue um that we could
never replicate anymore um and I think
and we've we've just gotten away from
that the the whole industry has been
commercialized and formul formul
formulaic they figured out the formulas
to every facet of it that um you can
only go so far with that right you can
only push the boundaries so much that um
guys like Lil Nas lap dancing on Satan
in his music video is like it's not even
surprising anymore so what is surprising
is when somebody these things about God
or somebody these things about um you
know against the ne when somebody these
things about Anthony fouchy right oh my
gosh I can't believe they said that so
um that is a great opportunity right 's
a there's a it's another Silver Lining
that I look at it's like you have to go
through I call this time period like
this especially in America because we're
still a young country but like it we're
going through like a pubescent time
where it's ugly and our voice is
changing and it's we don't really know
who we are but on the other side of that
you become this mature individual I
think Humanity as a collective is going
through this time where we're going oo
of us are going like let's slow down a
little bit and and not charge ahead in
the name of progress and then there's
other there's another half of us that
are just ready to devote our time to
Oculus glasses and live out our life
doing that thing but um I digress but
yeah there's an opportunity there yeah
there's an opportunity there and I think
frankly so I spent a lot of time
thinking about the way Society is
organized and I consider myself um a
liberal but I consider myself a
liberal because I don't think we have a
choice but to change if I thought we
could survive by not
changing um I would say change is we we
have just witnessed the huge danger of
change but in this case I think we have
to change sufficiently to get to a a new
stable place because where we are we
can't stay and we can't go back neither
of those are possible so anyway I call
myself a reluctant radical I don't want
radical change I know radical change is
dangerous but I don't think we have a
choice that said I think we we stand at
a Crossroads there is a choice in front
of us and I think it's very once you
figure out how to look at it it's
actually quite clear and pretty easy to
describe and you'll forgive me for
taking this digression here but uh in
light of your special position in uh
phrasing things so that
people can can grasp them on a deeper
level it's worth talking to you about
it there's something that I would call
the west and the West is the
idea that you should not be trying to
rig the world in favor of your people
what you should want is a set of rules
that doesn't rig it in favor of
anybody's people and in such a world you
deprioritize the population that you
come come from and you collaborate with
whoever brings something to the table
that makes them good to collaborate with
and we all get wealthier we get we are
enriched by collaborating with people on
the basis that it's a good thing to do
and that is in competition with the way
the world used to work the world used to
be all about One lineage displacing
another and the problem is that the
system that I call the West is better in
every way it's safer it's fairer it's
more liberating it's more fun it uh
makes us all wealthier but it's also
more fragile it's a much uh more
difficult state to provide the
conditions to maintain it and when
economic growth comes apart it collapses
and it collapses back into this lineage
against lineage violence so my point to
the world kind of
is this is the choice are we going to
figure out how to stable Iz the West we
never finished it we never got all the
way there we never completely gave up on
what race you came from but we did get
pretty close and now it's going
backwards because the growth has run out
and now we're looking at each other with
suspicion and the answer is okay well
that's that's the gate way to hell we're
going backwards into hell and we have a
choice and we could say hey maybe we all
fight that together right let's not go
back to hell and if we can't fight it
off fine at least we tried but but yeah
at the moment when I see the West coming
apart and I don't think people know what
it means right yeah I think humanity and
America peaked in the 80s and 90s it's
like we were almost there you know you
grew up you I grew up in a world where
you didn't really think about the color
of the skin of the person you were
watching on TV or who you were listening
to and then all of a sudden you know
after 2000 basically you know for me 911
was like the the de
that was the mark that everything
changed in my life I was 18 at the time
um and all of a sudden these things
started coming into play that I never
thought about and and
um uh yeah we started digressing or we
started going backwards from there I
think and
um I think that uh people are wanting to
I don't think that I think that that the
way for for is community I think that um
you know it's not going to come from the
top down and we're going to vote
somebody in and uh they're going to save
the day and change everything I think
it's going to have to come incrementally
through it starts in your home and then
it your neighbors and then your
neighborhood and getting back to taking
control of things I think that's why so
many people want to grow their own food
again or homeschool again you're seeing
these resurces of control because we've
given up on on that over the last 100
years for the sake of convenience and
that's what I mean like earlier when I
say I think Humanity collectively is
going hold on a second you know maybe we
we don't need to wear goggles all day
and and eat printed meat 3D printed
meat that is a really sad picture you
paint there I mean it's not like I
haven't seen it but yeah you you you you
put a pretty fine point on it um so I do
want to go back to one thing you said
it's not like we're going to vote
somebody in and that's going to fix
things and I agree with you on the other
hand I would ask people not to dismiss
the possibility that voting somebody in
who could um unplug the
Matrix would be a good step to allow us
to discover those other things that we
need to figure out on our own and do in
our communities you know I mean
essentially we have an antagonist I
don't know what its name is I don't
think it's the
WF but there's obviously something that
doesn't care about us that is
constructing mechanisms of control is uh
plotting to unhook our ability to
discuss what it's up to and decide
whether or not we're going to fight it
and whatever that thing is it would not
be bad to have a champion in high office
who agreed that it was
intolerable yeah yeah it's um
it's just interesting you know watching
the shape of things right now
because I I do get very pessimistic
about the next election cycle because it
took me a long time to think to even
consider going from teenager into adult
to go like oh maybe my vote does matter
but then you vote and you contribute and
you you you feel proud about it um but
going into this next next election
between World War II starting up and
another planemic On The Rise and agenda
2030 I feel like there's so many things
in play right now that might even just
prevent us from even getting to that
point so um yeah I don't know but but
you're right in that sense that you know
it would be great still to have somebody
there that does align with
us in that
sense that is it's at least it's at
least worth a shot yeah right I mean
that's what yeah that's where we are as
Americans I think you know it's like you
don't want to you still have to be
hopeful about
it well yeah I
mean yeah do you have to be hopeful you
know I I think I
think there are two things that motivate
people one of them is Hope and the other
one is fear and I must tell you I I
am motivated at this moment by my fears
of what happens if we do not get a
handle on
this um
so if I didn't think there was any hope
I wouldn't do it but right um it's not
the uh well there's overwhelmingly hope
and we just got to get the job done it's
the holy crap we are uh right we have
been cornered by something and uh this
is not the moment uh for cowardice right
yeah I mean it's it's a it's definitely
a I mean we're in the middle of a war
it's psychological obviously but like
um yeah I just went blank as you were
talking to me but um I think
that what I was going to say
was the fear that drives us is it
transitions into hope right it's like I
spoke out because of my fear of the
world that my kids were going to grow up
in but I H you have to be hopeful
otherwise you know what's the point in
doing what we're all doing because I do
believe that underneath all this froth
there's just a bunch of like crap thrown
on top of the best time to ever be alive
like really it should be the best time
to live right now we have these
incredible tools and we're all connected
it's just that they're all corrupted and
tainted and controlled so and then and
then you toss on ridiculous things like
you know the uh the the trans movement
and things like that where kid that's
your biggest worry in life is whether or
not to cut off your penis so you could
be a woman like that's that's not really
what life is like supposed to that's not
supposed to be something that you worry
about in life it's not it's not a sign
of a healthy moment right yeah it's an
indication that we're fairly far off
road here yeah but but it's also an
indication that like things are so
good in a in a way that that's what
people have to worry about right and and
so then there's that on top but then
they have to create these you know every
day we're pummeled with something new
these distractions and these things to
try to keep us um keep us in fear and I
think that you know for me personally
like every day it's just sort of making
me stronger this the last three years
have made me I'm not I'm I'm not the
same person I was three years ago and
I'm much stronger than I ever was um and
I'm willing to take risks I wasn't
willing to take and and every week that
the more ridiculous it gets the more I
just sort of go I sort of laugh at it
you know it's become so absurd that you
almost have no choice but to just turn
around and laugh at it which I think is
is
also you know one of the best ways to
fight against the absurdity and darkness
is just by mocking it and laughing at it
that's one of the reasons like why I
wrote sad little man why I call out some
of these dark figures is because that's
the best way to belittle them it's just
laughing and saying you can't you can't
hurt me you're just a sad little man
right yep no I I think you're exactly
right and there's something so utterly
powerful about the ability of music not
only to articulate that point right I
can articulate that point but what you
do by phrasing it musically is you
actually place it in the correct
emotional context for people to feel it
well beyond their ability to just
comprehend it
and uh you know I wish there were words
to explain how important that is that
people actually
understand at an emotional level that
this is where this is the position from
which they want to be speaking they do
not want to be doing the sad little
man's business they want to be speaking
back to the sad little man
and um anyway it is it is a unique
property of music and a unique gift of
the musician that they are able to guide
somebody emotionally to the deeper
meaning of of of a truth like that it's
very powerful
yeah it is interesting to see the um you
know we are there's the side that I'm
sure you find yourself in a lot where
it's you're arguing stats and data and
um which doctor said what or which
scientist said what but as a musician
like it's been interesting as to be on
this side of it because it is an
emotional thing I think that's it's one
of the reasons why we share docu um
minaries or memes even you know it it
hits Us in an emotional way and there're
these little tools that we have that
when you can't find the right words or
somebody's exhausted from the articles
that you're sending them you can sort of
just place this piece of music out there
or this video or this image whatever it
may be and it resonates and does
everything you would have wanted it to
do other you know the point that you
were trying to drive home um comes
through GRE so much easier that
way yeah um and I also think you know
your point about humor and and laughing
at these things rather than cowering is
powerful and
even I wish people
understood that you know they have a
fear of being isolated that was the
primary tool that was used to manipulate
them and to turn them into Savage witch
Hunters but people need to spot that
actually the people they were hunting
are in the position that they would
prefer to be in right to have a a
telephone full of contacts that you know
are not going to believe [__] about
you people who will stand up for you you
know who wouldn't leave you to bleed on
a battlefield that's a hell of a a set
of contacts to have especially in a
confusing era like this and so anyway
yes you know those of us on the the
dissident side took a lot of of uh of
hits on our
well-being I still wouldn't have
preferred to be on the other side for
anything in fact I find the idea
horrifying right um so if people if
people can get that if they can allow
you to lead them emotionally to a place
of feeling powerful talking back to to
the man as it were um then that's a big
piece of the
battle yeah it's been uh interesting to
get messages from people that I've
actually sent me that you know saying I
I showed your video to my mom and dad um
who got the first two shots and it and
it really kind of you know Jarred him a
little bit um that's a very powerful
thing and that's something that I didn't
have really before in my music career
because you know I was just singing love
songs or you know we used your song our
wedding you know that is a beautiful
thing and I appreciated that you know on
a diff in a different way but
historically in the context of all this
to to know you have the ability
to shake somebody to wake him up a
little bit to crack that thickness you
know um open a little bit is is um
very um it's just just it's just a cool
thing I I traveled to the UK uh in
August and we I was there for an event
called Jam for freedom and it was three
days of music
artists um Freedom minded music artists
performing and there was speakers there
and it really showed me meeting people
there um what I had been working towards
the the purpose of my music because I I
arrived there and was meeting people and
there were it wasn't just one person
here and there there were families
coming up my son loves your song You
Know sad little man or Gates behind the
bars even which I thought was hilarious
that you know this nine-year-old boy was
you know totally into this song about
hating on Bill Gates um but then I when
I performed and I Sayang um God help us
all and you have all these people under
a tint singing your chorus back to you
singing the those words oh God help us
all um that's why I remain hopeful about
things because the unity is there you
know and all of the divisive rhetoric
that they try to split us apart with um
it it didn't make its way through you
know to some of us and we're all working
towards this new this new world and and
uh we talk about the great reset all the
time that but it's like we have an
opportunity to make it reset because the
world that we thought
existed um didn't really exist and
that's been revealed to us now so we get
to take the items that we liked about it
that we wanted to be real and actually
make them real you know that's kind of
the a crazy thought is to think about
the illusion turning the illusion into
reality
now I love that uh that view of it and I
can certainly you know I'm not um a
musician I I it's one of my great
regrets in life that I never picked up
an instrument but
um I can certainly imagine people
singing your chorus back to you and that
uh driving you forward realizing that
you actually Reach people I have that
effect a little bit it's obviously not
music but you know people come up and
tell me what what I've said that meant
something to them or what Heather and I
have discussed and it is very uh
reifying
but I also
agree we are in a very dark place but
that dark place is part of us having a
choice about what future we want and the
ability that people are finding to come
together and to
recognize that they don't want this they
know they don't want this I don't think
anybody who isn't profiting from it
directly wants a world like this the
world of 20 years ago as flawed as it
was wasn't this so
maybe maybe there is um
enough momentum and energy and there's
enough creativity amongst the small
number of artists who are now going to
be the only authentic music that we've
got and that can drive us to make the
right choices and at least take a shot
at uh putting the ship back on
course do you feel like that um outside
of music that there there's enough
people sort of waking
up well again I think the core issue is
this a huge number of people are
somewhat
awake and if they could be just driven
hey time to get up it's the rest of the
way you got to go right you you saw
something you know you don't want that
shot now let's work backwards and figure
out how it is is that people got to the
point of mandating something upon you
that you now realize was never in your
interest what does that mean what does
that require of you I do think that they
could wake up but at the moment they're
too comfortable because it's fine for
them not to say not to tell you that
they've switched sides not to even
confess to themselves that they're never
going to get the shot right so so I want
I want the people who are who are
somewhat awake to go the rest of the way
then there's a tremendous amount of
uh of Hope there are a lot of people a
huge a huge majority are are now
skeptical and then I will say the other
part of this which I I probably
shouldn't from the point of view of
leaving uh hope as intact as possible
the events of um the last week and a
little have
divided these Grassroots coalitions that
were
emerging there's something about the
crisis in the Middle East the attack on
Israel that is causing
people within the covid dissident
Community to forget what they
learned right they are now some of them
are participating
in more witch hunting and it's got to
stop but I think we have we have to also
learn the larger lesson which
is
you it sounds to me from what you've
said and you tell me if this is wrong it
sounds to me like um Co was the battle
that woke you up and it turned you into
a warrior which was not something that
you thought you were going to
be now the thing is covid was in many
ways clearest picture you're ever going
to get the nature of the covid battle
revealed all of the structures that that
jeopardize us
but having been through a few of these
battles now I know that each one has its
own nature and that people who see one
often miss another and anyway what we
need are people who actually put
together the larger lesson Co is just an
example of something Co is an example of
something larger and what you need to do
is have a model Rich enough that when
the next thing happens you're not fooled
even at the beginning right so anyway
yeah I hope that happens right yeah I
think
that you know I the thing that I'm sort
of bracing for is the next pandemic that
comes our way because it's going to
be you know likely aimed at children and
it's going to have a whole new set of
emotional manipulators or something that
that make a lot of people that felt
secure in how they feel right now now
have to second guess themselves and I am
at a point where it doesn't matter what
it is co related or not I don't I don't
take anything at face value anymore and
you have you can't rush into it
emotionally um no matter what it is
because you have to ask why you're
seeing it like we we know we live in a
time where the the wrong word can get
you censored and all of a sudden now
we're seeing all these graphic images
online from you know the the wars taking
place right now and you have to ask
yourself why you're seeing those why
you're allowed to see those like we know
there are Gatekeepers right on the other
end that's one of the big lessons that
we learned from the last few years is
that there's people on the other side
controlling what it is you're allowed to
see at least they're doing their best to
suppress what they don't want want you
to see sometimes they can just remove it
um but all of a sudden you know
particularly in the last week or so
we're seeing things that you would never
have anticipated seeing and we're
allowed to see it and so that's my
initial thought is why are we allowed to
see this and where is it coming from and
there's so there's a laundry list of
questions you have to ask yourself in in
in what what you're seeing we live the
the age of artificial intelligence for
crying out loud so you you you have to
question what it is that you're seeing
if it's real or not or you know and it's
not that you're denying that anything is
taking place it's not that you're saying
oh it's not happening at all it's just
why this edit right yeah why am I seeing
this edit yeah so I uh embrace your call
to skepticism and I do think that
is of all the lessons of the the
pandemic the clearest of them is that
it's the stuff that you accept at the
beginning because nothing specific has
told you to start questioning that you
regret later and really the people who
shined
earliest were the people who are already
very much on their guard so um I think
you know until and unless we are freed
from whatever it is that is working so
hard to control the information
environment a uh remaining on high alert
is always a good
idea yeah and how how I always wonder
how how much would change if we just
turned off the screens you know and we
just stepped away um because you know we
see it with media I mean we've already
kind of done it unintentionally with
media um you know people have learned to
distress the media more and more over
the last you know decade or so just
further and further drifting away so
we've kind of turned off the news a lot
of people still haven't but a lot of
people have um and it's like if we were
able to do the same thing um just with
social media in general getting back to
just reality in a sense
because you know whether it's a war or
it's co or it's just um you know a funny
cat video um it's the internet primarily
is is just little bits and pieces of
things happening but it's not really
reality so maybe you know we we just
slowly one by one start turning it off
or something I'm not sure well I I agree
with you about the uh the danger of not
turning it off I don't know about the
plausibility of getting people to turn
it off um but even just the
disconnection from things that are
not um
virtual the difference in the ability to
fool somebody who has expertise in the
physical world where things actually are
or are not true do or do not work um and
somebody whose world is entirely a
social reflection that's a huge a huge
gap and so even if people can't turn off
their screens just making sure that some
fraction of what they do is Meaningful
and physical is liable to make them uh
harder to
fool right yeah I
agree I don't know I'm trying to I'm
thinking about my kids I'm thinking
about you know our intention to keep
them screen free and I think that there
is that um
another generation that'll be coming up
behind the screen Focus generation that
will be detached more you know because
we there is parents out there paying
attention to what that that is doing to
their kids but yeah I hope so and I will
tell you my kids are uh are 19 and 17 um
and we did keep them away from screens
for a very long time and then ultimately
it didn't make sense because it was
necessary for them to play the role that
they played but I will tell you even
that even having kept it away until it
really just didn't make sense anymore I
wish I'd kept it away
longer interesting they've ended up
great but yeah my sense is the danger of
these things is so high that it would be
impossible to be too cautious yeah well
you think about just even just grown
adults I mean we all have our faults
with it you know I'm on way more than I
really should be because I am just
always constantly working you know so
you know unfortunately my kids see that
and I have to be conscious of it and you
know there there are areas where it
makes sense you know you should you
should learn that skill you know learn
learn a bit of photoshopping video
editing or whatever it is um but uh yeah
it's it's a balance It's Tricky Tricky
thing for sure
yep all right Brad is there anything
else you want to say before we wrap this
up uh not much just check out five times
August um you know look it up on the
internet find you five times August you
have a website right yeah five times
august.com is the website and uh we've
got records and CDs and all the digital
links on there and um you know look up
the videos if you get a chance if you
haven't heard the music before and um
you know I really I think it's it's it's
an important time for these artists that
are speaking up to really support what
they're saying these are the ways that
we really do change culture when I put
out the album silent War last year um to
my surprise when it came out we actually
made it to number five on the Amazon
charts next to Taylor Swift and Bruce
Springstein and that was really yeah
it's like amazing and it's a testament
to what this movement can do when we
vote with our dollars Like That album
was recorded recorded in my bedroom so
you know under a zero you know marketing
you know Z marketing budget so to be up
there next to those kind of artists um
that's what we can do so you know not
just myself but check out those other
artists as well yeah excellent and I
would just ask my audience this is uh if
you want to
embolden the people who stood up uh
giving them music music that speaks to
them and and urges them on is a very
wise investment so I hope people will
come find you at five times august.com
and I hope people will check out those
videos which are available for free
online they really are well worth
watching not just listening to and
anyway Brad thanks for joining me I'll
see you on the battlefield and uh thanks
to everybody else for listening in
thanks for having me ciao
[Music]